welcome to this video playing
international haces zet from the US
there is no name end up so Kings Indian
gruene thought Kings Indiana days and
maybe I can vary a bit here with my
lines playing the glicca rich all right
s60 there's castles what if I play d 5
or maybe it's probably also move here
nigeria's it's the most logical move
yeah I'm not quite sure if this is
really a good line for white but it's
looking normal enough 95 may be tricky
yeah what now is it really that I need
to take on f5 and then a form probably
you threatening h6 with winning a pawn
so i probably must take
f-for smile my next move I wanted to
castle first it looked a bit strange
without castling yes this is the the
internal problem here right no enters on
his expert has a hard time to keep the
spawn and needs to get some compensation
going I'm trying my best here like
before and c5 this type of stuff d takes
e4 Bishop c4 we simply has d5 here mmm
well that's terribly bad Oh what am i
doing him
but this is like totally totally lost
okay hoping for d for Bishop c4 I mean
okay that's a very cheap trick but maybe
I can get in night b-52 d for this would
help a bit not much but a bit at least
he can just place his 6am would have
been a good move and not that this is
bad i mean it was just what i was
thinking about c6 preventing even I'd be
five but ok it's not a problem for black
wow really that's surprising I mean okay
he can do that and grab the material but
still um I am Jack i think i was i was
even to us before so what is this now
it's like just an exchange right yeah
the exchange it's still terrible for me
okay I wonder if I'm threatening g for
you okay fine
take it and f5 there is ok if I manage
to get in m5 somehow there is c7 hanging
but I don't I don't see how I can do it
really let me try like that two minutes
12 there is also g4 which would trap the
rook now yeah G for a beat eggs yeah
it's not great iam not really yeah well
I'm still alive but certainly this is
not one of the greatest games ever that
I played not not good yeah
yeah but maybe I can do something with
the pawn cm this is why I went to why I
agree to the Queen trade maybe like here
now get this first and walking up to
this age for that's not really good
maybe this one first
okay it may be rookie evade is a good
move I / should be 60 came that's not
not not so great this is not totally
easy for YF or black I mean he still
needs to be precise if I get in King III
and g4 I'm not not worse absolutely not
can can play the snow rookies six maybe
and then the counter sec here rg6
yeah this is still interesting between
five and ten the f5 okay x thing I need
to have ready to protect this so that i
can play looked you one next trying to
force them to move the pawn b3 King III
arteaga for this is terrible for black
yeah the whole thing went totally wrong
for em maybe d5 here first take them
check check this of course I overlooked
hmm not good not good
I'm not sure that this is winning from
black
Jabba had a better position even before
just I just didn't see what he played
them do you three and then drew takes
I always have the jeep on for my counter
play some I don't think he can win maybe
just by by one move or something grah
our third game yeah of course draw I
mean nothing to do but we I was totally
busted in the middle of it I mean at the
beginning of it but around here I think
this is this is getting tricky computers
unimpressed same legs winning I don't
believe it hard to believe but ok now
maybe it always gets in this counter sec
to enter but I wonder about this here
yeah this is of course not right I need
to tick with the bishop I didn't want
him to get to f5 maybe ourselves at the
two too optimistic that sound this I
wonder maybe this is lost them just by
one move or something but I'm not sure I
can cook like Troy here what's the best
possible scenario you get you can try to
to do that check and see check if you
can check check now ok this should be
very good for black yeah I probably you
can force that the king is near the
pawns here and black is much more active
I had also win the podium so this is one
equally could have done yeah this went
totally belly-up right
the start I mean this night to his six
stuff was was just just not working at
all ahead relied on that but you can
just play d5 and tier just c6 is totally
killing everything yeah this was just a
bad game right thanks for watching